that's burned in my memory from the 18th
century it's pure and AZ's the Colosseum
or a model the size of a basketball I
built this around a basketball evidence
the scales evidence by the red cup
behind it and that model can be put into
a larger piece as a seed and that seed
can grow into a bigger piece and that
piece can fill a very very large space
but it can funnel down into a video
that's just made from my iPhone of the
puddle outside of my studio and a rainy
night so this is an after image of the
painting made in my memory and even that
painting can fade as memory does so this
is the scale of a very small image from
my sketchbook you can see how it can
explode to a subway station that spans
three blocks and you could see how going
into the subway station is like a
journey through the pages of a
sketchbook and you can see sort of a
diary of war
Ritt across the public space and you're
turning the pages of 20 years of artwork
as you move through the subway but even
that sketch is actually has a different
origin has origin in a sculpture that
climbs a six story building and is
scaled to a cat from the year 2000 to I
remember that because I had two black
cats at the time and this is an image of
a work from Japan that you can see the
after made in the subway or work in
Venice where you see the image edged in
the wall or how sculpture that I did at
SF MoMA in 2001 and created this kind of
dynamic line how I stole that to create
a dynamic line as you descend down into
the subway itself and this merging of
mediums is really interesting to me so
how can you take a line that pulls
tension like a sculpture and put it into
a print or then use line like a drawing
in a sculpture to create a dramatic
perspective or how can a painting mimic
the process of printmaking
how can an installation use the camera's
lens to frame a landscape how can a
painting on string become a moment in
Denmark in the middle of a track and how
on the High Line can you create a piece
that camouflages itself into the nature
itself and become a habitat for the
nature around it and I'll just end with
two pieces that I'm making now this is a
piece called fallen sky that's going to
be a permanent commissioned in Hudson
Valley and it's kind of the planetarium
finally come down and grounding itself
in the earth and this is a work from
2013 that's going to be reinstalled have
a new life in the reopening of MoMA and
it's a piece that the tool itself is the
sculpture so the pendulum as it swings
is used as a tool to create the piece so
each of the piles of objects go right up
to one centimetre
to that to the tip of that pendulum so
you have this combination of the lull of
that beautiful swing but also the
tension that it constantly could destroy
the
itself and so it doesn't really matter
where any of these pieces end up because
the real point for me is that they end
up in your memory over time and they
generate ideas beyond themselves thank
you
[Applause]